PROFESSOR: So let's look
at a little more detail
at the equilibrium size
of respiratory droplets
that are emitted
during breathing,
or coughing, or speaking.
And the key idea is that these
droplets are not pure liquid.
As explained in the wells
curve, pure droplets
that are small enough
will shrink completely
and evaporate.
However, these droplets
contain a significant amount
of solutes.
And those solutes, in the case
of mucus coming from your lungs
or from your vocal cords,
your nasal pharynx,
are full of proteins and other
macromolecules, carbohydrates.
And also there are always
in bodily fluids plenty
of dissolved salts such as
sodium and chloride or calcium
or potassium ions.
Also, in saliva, many of
these species are present,
although it's not quite
as thick of a liquid.
And of course, virions as well
will find themselves in here,
and it also constitutes solutes.
So the idea is that we don't
just have a pure liquid.
So there is some
initial volume fraction
of solute in the liquid.
And in addition to that,
most of these liquids --
sorry, the solutes
I should say are
charged and thus hygroscopic.
What that means is that,
of course, the salt,
those ions are literally charged
species, but also the proteins
and other
macromolecules that many
charge residues and sites
along the molecule, which
attract water.
And essentially,
there is a layer
of bound water solvating all of
these species I just mentioned,
including the virus.
So I'll just sketch
that there's lots
of bound water, which is
surrounding each species,
including the virus.
There's essentially
a layer of water
mostly around these molecules
here and other species.
So it's solutes
plus the bound water
that's coming from solvation
of these molecules in liquid.
So that water is
pretty firmly attached.
And even if you dry the
material, a lot of that water
will still be left over.
It takes a significant amount
of energy to remove it.
And so if we think that --
if we describe there is initial
volume of the droplet V_O,
and a radius R_0, so
let's say it's initially
a circular droplet, there
is an initial amount
of solid, V_s, which is
phi_s^0 times V_0.
So there's a certain amount of
solutes in there which cannot
be removed.
So the water can evaporate,
but the solutes will not.
So let's think a
little bit about what
the consequences of that are.
So let me do a brief
derivation here
for looking at the
thermodynamics of this system.
And the key idea is just
to get to the final result.
I don't want to dwell on the
details of thermodynamics.
But an important concept
here is the relative humidity
of the air.
So there's moisture in the air.
There's water vapor.
And it's at a certain level.
So we often write that
rh for relative humidity.
And that can be defined as
the concentration of vapor,
water vapor in the air relative
to the vapor concentration
that would be in equilibrium
with pure liquid.
So when the concentration
water vapor gets high enough,
eventually you start to
nucleate water droplets.
And you start to have
condensation water.
That's essentially how
rain forms from the clouds.
So that's that ratio.
So relative humidity
is telling you
how close you are to basically
having, water liquid water come
out of the air.
OK, now, the relative
humidity also tells us
something about how far you
are from that phase transition
point.
And there's a very
simple approximation.
I'll put approximate here.
We can also write that
this is -- scales with, and is --
can be in fact close
to the liquid volume
fraction in equilibrium
inside the drop.
So that'll be the water volume
fraction of water liquid
inside the droplet.
At least you can see here in
this relationship when this
volume fraction is
one -- in other words,
we have pure water --
then the relative
humidity is 100%.
OK, and on the other hand, when
you have, let's say, only 50%
water, over here, that's like
having relative humidity 50%.
This can be derived by
more careful consideration
of the ideal entropy of
mixing where essentially
this term here is take
into account the excluded
volume and the fact that all
the sites in this droplet
are not available for the water.
So they're being excluded by all
the solutes and the bound water
that are present.
And similarly, we have
a buildup of free energy
in the bulk as well.
So basically, this comes
from some thermodynamic
considerations of equilibrium
between water vapor
and water liquid.
We can write this as 1
minus the volume fraction
in equilibrium of the solid.
OK, now the thing is that
we can now write this.
So if we multiply through, we
can write this as 1 minus the --
so what is the volume -- so
when we get to equilibrium,
this droplet is going
to change its shape.
It's going to reach
a new shape, which
we're going to calculate our
new volume, V_equilibrium.
And so what this would
would be V_solid,
which is phi_s^0*V_0
divided by V_equilibrium.
So it's going to be new
volume, V_equilibrium, which
will be achieved then.
And then we'll end up with the
equilibrium volume fraction.
So if I take these
equations here,
and I solve, I get a
fundamental result, which
is that the equilibrium
volume of the droplet
relative to the initial
volume is equal to,
well, we have put this
on the other side.
That'll be (1-RH).
And we divide that out.
And we find that it's the
initial volume fractions
solutes divided by (1-RH).
That is our key result. And
let's plot what this looks
like.
So if we prop the
relative humidity
on the horizontal axis,
from 0 to 100%, so at 100%,
the water vapor is
saturating the air.
And you would start to
nucleate and condensed water
liquid from that.
At 0, the air is completely dry.
And there is essentially
no water vapor present.
So that's the range.
And typical comfortable rooms
have a relative humidity
around 50%.
This is a typical number.
And let's plot on this axis
the equilibrium volume.
It could also be the
equilibrium radius
because I should say that
if there are spheres,
that this is also equal to
R_equilibrium divided by (R_0)^3.
So I can also take
a cube root of this.
And I would have
the ratio of radii.
So we would know if we started
a certain radius, what's
the final radius.
OK, so we can talk about volume.
We can talk about radius.
So here is the initial
size of the drop.
And somewhere down
here is V_s,
which is the solute volume,
which is phi_s^0*V_0.
Now what is this value?
It depends on the
kind of liquid.
So saliva is mostly
water with some salt
and a few other molecules.
But in saliva, the
volume fraction phi_s^0
is 0.5% in saliva.
OK, so that's just
gives you a sense.
So this is quite
far down, right?
But then, if you
look in mucus, it
depends which mucus
you're talking about.
But the mucus that comes from
the lungs or from the pharynx,
it can vary.
But what has also been
measured in droplets
that are emitted by breathing
is that this can range anywhere
from 5% to 10%.
So a fairly significant amount
of the volume of the droplet
is containing all these
molecules and the bound water
around that.
Now we know that because
mucus is very sticky.
It's a non-Newtonian fluid.
It doesn't maintain a
nice round shape even.
It can have a regular shape.
It flows slowly.
It has a high viscosity.
And that's because
it has a large amount
of these hygroscopic solutes.
So mucus might be a
little bit higher up.
But in any case,
what you then find is
we can sketch different
regions of this plot now.
So this curve this
formula drive here,
when the relative humidity
is zero, we start here.
So that's saying when
there's no water in the air,
you completely dry the droplet.
And you're left just with the
molecules, the solid molecules,
and possibly the
bound water around it,
depending on how dry
the air actually is.
And then it rises up
and blows up at 100%.
So when you get to
100%, then droplets
are getting really large.
And if you actually
hit 100%, then you
can't really speak of
an equilibrium size
because you'll just start to
get lots and lots of water.
So that's that limit.
And so now we can look at
three different regimes
of the kinds of droplets
that we'd expect to see.
So down here at 0%
or close to zero,
we have a dried droplet
nuclei as they're called
in the public health field.
These respiratory aerosols,
if they completely dry out,
and you're left with just
these solutes, then that's
called a droplet nucleus.
So it doesn't
necessarily mean it's
a nucleus for phase
transformation
as we use that term in, say,
engineering or in physics.
But it's really just
refers to the core
of just the hydrated solutes.
So if I could sketch what that
looks like, that would be--
for example, all
those molecules I just
sketched there
might be condensed
into some little blob,
which, by the way,
could include a virion.
In fact, it could even
be just one virion
if that were all
that were in there.
And you would have a little
bit of bound water around it.
But you essentially have a dried
up blob of just the solutes.
OK, and so that --
and then, of course,
the smallest volume you can
get is just the initial solute
volume that you started
with, plus the bound water.
On the other end, if we are near
100% relative humidity, then
the fact that these are
hygroscopic solutes, which
like to have water near them,
will form as a nucleation site
to actually cause
more and more water
to grow and be absorbed
into this droplet.
And not only do the
droplets not shrink,
as predicted by the Wells
curve for a pure liquid,
but they can actually grow.
So if the size here is
small enough to begin with,
let's say it were a several-micron
droplet to begin with,
but it contains a lot
of solutes, and we're
at very high humidity,
actually the particle can grow.
So over here, we could end up
with an even larger droplet
than we started with where
now because the humidity is
so high, and we have the same
number of molecules in there
that I sketched before,
that's more dilute now.
And there's maybe a virus
or a virion here and there.
And of course, there's
also some salt.
But basically, the
droplet is growing.
So here we have
hygroscopic growth
and also we have what's
called deliquescence, which
refers to water that's absorbing
around these salt molecules
and even causing some
other molecules or charges
on these macromolecules
to dissolve into solution
because it's more and more
water present
and it can solvate more species.
And so whereas
hygroscopic growth
refers to water being
absorbed into a more
solid-like framework,
you can also
be generating more aqueous
solution, which is deliquescence.
So basically, the droplet
can actually grow.
And that would be like when
you're here, let's just say.
And this might be
when you're here.
And then, of course, when
you're at 50% relative humidity,
you can see the
droplet has shrunken
but not all the way down to the
initial solute volume fraction,
but something larger.
And in fact, if the
relative humidity is 50%,
you end up at exactly twice
the solid volume fraction.
So if the solid volume
fraction of mucus is 10%,
you may end up
with a droplet that
is maybe 20% of the volume.
So maybe it looks
something like this.
OK, and so we have a little
bit of shrinking going on.
And maybe there's even a
virus in there as well.
But there is still
plenty of water.
And so you can see also now
the value of having solutes
in mucus in terms of making the
virions more viable and more
easily transmittable because
they hold onto the water.
So that the virion is
in a stable environment.
So that when it ends up being
inhaled into someone else's
lungs that it can
then more easily
diffuse out of that region
and infect the host cells.
In contrast, if you have
a nearly pure liquid
that the virion is in, let's
say pure water or even saliva,
which is actually
mostly water, then
the droplet will shrink
by a factor of 100.
And it might be just literally
a virion with a [couple of
ions] just enveloped
with a tiny bit of water.
And maybe that, in some
cases, would be not as viable
of a situation for the virions.
So basically the
mucus fragments are
likely to be the more common
source of the aerosols that
will stay in the air
and remain infectious.